the new york times smarter living editor
takes on the cost of indulgence in a new
article headline here's some money
advice just buy the coffee
he argues that spending money on simple
pleasures like a good lunch or a nice
haircut will not make or break your
budget Tim Herrera's with us good
morning I have this I'm really happy to
hear this that it's okay to spend that
money splurge rather than save it yeah
so I feel like there's been sort of a
demonization of these tiny little
everyday purchases and sort of this
mischaracterize mischaracterizations
they're non-essential like are they're
not essential in the fact that we'll die
if we don't buy a morning coffee sure
but if it's something that makes people
happy something that brings joy to their
lives there's really nothing wrong with
relatively small price to pay it's not
the argument Tim though the everyday
part of it it's okay to splurge now and
again but isn't that aren't the expert
Suze Orman and others saying you know
it's the everyday routine that you do
that makes a difference and it is true
that these tiny purchases can add up and
there are ways around that and there it
is kind of rooted in like good advice
which is be mindful of your spending
track it like make the decision like is
that something I really need but we've
just taken it to such a far extreme and
we've taken it away that sort of misses
the broader picture that you know the
reason so many of us have such anxiety
and stress around money is wage
stagnation and implications from the
great recession and health care costs
and college debt loans things like that
and so to put to pin all of our you know
stress and anxiety around money about
these everyday tiny purchases really
just misses the point and it makes
people feel bad about these things it's
fine to buy a coffee so maybe the thing
not standing between you and owning a
home is not the avocado toast you have
is to take one item which I think the
times is written about but if you're not
gonna have the avocado toast every day
or the coffee every day how many days is
okay how many days is too many I mean
whatever works and you know it can be
really helpful and really important for
people to keep a budget and be able to
track their spending I know what they
can spend and what they can allot to
these non-essential everyday items
um so we'll drive when you say not
essentially you think they're essential
they're the things that make life worth
living right like if you want to get a
nice haircut get a nice haircut it'll
make you feel great you know you don't
wanna join a gym join a gym again that's
not something that's gonna prevent you
from buying 80% of the people are
basically living
take the paycheck yeah where where do
you find the money because everybody's
like you need to save yes where do you
say and there's Twitter and it really
doesn't matter like what your income
looks like and what your level looks
like but you know the biggest thing that
people can do to improve their financial
situation is really find a way to
improve your job situation find a better
paying job and so you know we we try to
encourage people to find find new skills
how can you equip yourself to become a
more a higher earning person change your
income because really that's I hear
people outside going have you been on
LinkedIn lately but there's so many
factors that are out of our control like
we don't really have a handle on like
you know I can't change the wider
economy what I can do is try to equip
myself so in the future I can line up
things that are going to make my
situation better what about the question
that your mom used to say when you're a
little do you want it or do you need it
yeah versus need question but you know
another part to look at or another way
to look at that idea is your financial
well-being versus your emotional
well-being you know if it makes you
happy and it brings you joy to you know
maybe splurge on like a nice pair of
jeans there's emotional need right that
latte we make those decisions but you
just have to you know be okay with what
you're making these decisions around and
kind of go in knowing what you're going
to sacrifice all right you might be
waiting for you in the hallway I want to
see how Tim lives his life he's cut back
on socks
[Laughter]